sorry that's real can you count for me
yep
one kind of excited of what's gonna be
the outcome of all this because I'm sure
but I will discover things about myself
sharing my insecurities with a stranger
is just so nerve-wracking I don't often
share that kind of my insecurities with
just anybody I don't know I just I feel
kind of nervous how you doing man good
how are you nice to meet you I'm Janine
nice to meet you to meet you
[Music]
okay so here we go so what I wrote was
Kevin you live in California you moved
across the entire country to pursue your
dreams
but you left your family behind you are
the only person on your team who isn't
bilingual how can you work for it all
that next team but don't even speak
Spanish you're a fake
latina sorry
that's real your mother loves you so
much and your siblings idolize you but
you do is such a terrible job staying in
touch with them how could you do that
when your mom was a refugee and she
nearly escaped death for you and your
family you're such a disappointment
move aside for the real Latinos you are
too sensitive too emotional that makes
you weak you let people walk all over
you all the time no one takes you
seriously you are so selfish dad was
right you're not good enough you're
you're a disgrace of a son and at this
rate you'll you'll lose everyone you're
going to be alone
and maybe that's what you deserve
nothing you say matters you aren't
enough and no one cares about your story
damn I know what it's like to not know
my home language well just because you
don't know your language doesn't mean
you don't have a story because other
Latina women will see you and they'll
feel feel like they can live vicariously
through you because you're over here
pursuing what you want and what you love
I don't know you enough to to know who
you are but I base most of my
relationships off of energy it doesn't
seem to me that you have a negative
energy it's yeah it's giving power to to
the wrong emotions
I think it's perspective it's just
focusing on the wrong things Janine you
are a mental mess lately you've over
drawn from your emotional piggy bank and
you've lost control of who you are and
what you love how did you get to this
point you have the house of your dreams
and you don't want to be near it you
want it the most beautiful woman and you
got it except she doesn't make you happy
you have everything yet you feel nothing
you're not doing enough your parents and
your friends are so overwhelmingly
supportive of you and yet you still
can't get a grip are you even good
enough to pursue the path you've taken
because
you chose the riskiest feel to be in and
you're going to but everyone down if
you're not good enough you're alone and
the only light shine you on you is that
of your family and it's slowly dimming
because they're becoming bigger and
better and stronger and you remain the
same unhappy and without the guts to do
anything about it
who are you you're certainly not the
person you thought you were
you're a roller coaster of good and bad
days are you even going to get better
your looks your weight your thinning
hair and your makeup just everything
needs to get better as soon as you
started reading it was just like the
first line is was like you're a mental
mess you know and I totally feel that I
totally have said that to myself so many
times and it just feels like it feels
like you're broken I know we always tell
other people like you're too hard on
yourself but you are too hard on
yourself when you talked about your
family that like resonates with me
because I like care about my family so
much and sometimes when it's just like
they're doing their thing and then
you're kind of just like there you feel
like what am I doing with my life
being out here and doing things you were
fighting for something and I don't think
you've given up on what you want so I
don't think you should also give up on
who you are in yourself like when I
first saw you
there's just isn't light and it just
kind of dimmed down once we got into
this place of like sadness and just
self-doubt for so long I I have talked
to people but but never never spoke and
never communicated what I was feeling
out sometimes just writing what you feel
and saying it out loud or simply just
talking to somebody even if it's a
stranger my
it might save you from drowning I
definitely need to be better about being
okay with being weak
I don't not weak alright what is what is
it it's a strength to be able to express
your emotions it's not being weak at all
sometimes I think we just need to give
ourselves a break and just like feel
like we're doing the best that we can
and we are good we're gonna make it
we're gonna do something with this I
appreciate them I just need to be nicer
to her so I was like oh my god I can't
believe we talked like this we wouldn't
talk to anyone else like this you know I
don't talk to myself I think we learned
a lot today about each other and just
about ourselves and I just wanted to say
like thank you I really appreciate that
you shared your story with me thank you
so much thank you this is wonderful yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]